you went to the hospital for what
heatstroke today yeah
a jivin are you bad fast but I'm good
that's okay I'm here you're here
yes
so Tammy where you from originally
you're from LA and how long you been
living on the street and what what were
the circumstances that got you doubt
Harry
mental illness yeah
your family
[Music]
what do you mean as far as you're
concerned
[Music]
so again I'm family
what do you do for money here you get
the government yeah yeah nice town
and what are you good - I don't you cook
here yeah really good for you
I think yeah you do
[Music]
is this how you pass the time
nice
really that was sold on the way sure
I'll grab you dinner too if you want
you're what there you go
I think that means you're dating Carrie
your friends here on the street I don't
know nobody on it yeah
that would be totally what so you
contract with anybody outside so it's
just you all by yourself
you get lonely depressing like that
there lie to me dealing yeah beautiful I
love to start
sorry miss Jo it's okay
but I'm okay I've got my head you know
what I did
I do they gentleman's like that guy said
[ __ ] that step I hate and shook my head
off [ __ ] out the door I just had to be
by myself my way cool go yeah that's
what I learned to do eat so pull off put
I didn't but I took it slow going back
you know took all the shady sides of the
street which is what I was forgot okay
yeah what's the worst thing you that's
this happen to you here that's right
some guys playing to attack me in
Merchant but I don't know bill way [ __ ]
like that happens all the time
hey these guys out here then they're the
buzz of everything you've been raped
here no I really wanna drag got stabbed
what's a the one that tried got stabbed
oh is that right where the pan he's
looking at and get my net needle out
or the Kurdish it had been worse yeah
whose life I have crochet hook i have
met Neil stop that mom that'll hurt yeah
but you chose more going up beneath oh
it's right there was important done when
I thought that society was so
dysfunctional it might have made me
normal yeah sorry about that
but what me hey don't they say a high IQ
comes with a mental illness comes along
for the ride
yeah I heard the radio type Jill flippin
zhu jiying [ __ ] tell me about your
childhood
yeah yeah later the worst night man that
was that was that uh dodging yo you're
adopted
yeah at what age like right away three
and a half yeah what happened to your
parents
oh I found out my brother died on the
way to the hospital
from something other that happened at
the home I desire nothing find out
[Music]
and did you ever have contact with your
real parents ever every mother I got
about three paragraphs and my legs are
tossed it yeah oh you didn't read it
ladies brother I would've had died and
my other sister had Down syndrome really
yeah you're the lucky one
no he just said goof hey you don't have
to suffer about nothing and you have
children how many child no kids no kids
yep face it they're all [ __ ] yeah
never married ever again that was a real
[ __ ] oh you were married how many
times before four times yeah you're a
jerk yeah you're funny
is that easier what sauce the way of
putting it okay what's the harsher way
of putting it it was so good it lays
their ground the way and laugh at it do
you have plans for down the road
this puddle - there was five times
whoopsie good because that's all we
really do anyway